nuclear fusion has been a pipe dream for
decades always 20 years away never 19.
it's easy to get jaded about this
technology and write it off as
impossible especially when nuclear
fission already exists and is being
underutilized
but by the end of this video I hope I
can change that feeling and get you as
excited as I am about the potential of
this technology if we as a civilization
actually pull it off and invent a
cost-effective nuclear fusion power
plant it would change the face of
society Clean safe fuels will allow
every country in the world to benefit
from this technology allowing countries
around the world to be energy
independent preventing one of the
leading causes of conflicts around the
world as we fight for control of energy
sources
cheap reliable and abundant energy is
the foundation of every sci-fi utopian
society it would solve our issues with
climate change allow us to Electrify
industries that require fossil fuels
like steel smelting allow us to create
entirely new industries that have been
held back by energy costs like water
desalination providing the world with
fresh clean water to irrigate our lands
and turn Barren wastelands to fertile
pastures ushering in an era of Clean
safe abundance a utopian future that has
been dreamed of for decades
nuclear fusion experiments have been
underway since the very earliest years
of the cold war with the first
generators firing up in the 1950s in
both the USA and USSR the Soviet Union
approached the problem with the Tokamak
design while the Americans used a
slightly different approach the
stellarator each design attempts to
solve the same problem Fusion in essence
isn't terribly complicated we can make
new elements by combining smaller
elements and in the process release a
lot of energy however to successfully
combine elements we need to overcome the
electromagnetic repulsion like pushing
two North Poles the magnet together
atoms will repel each other in order to
force them together we need to input a
tremendous amount of energy but we can't
just grab individual atoms and force
them together like magnets instead we
need to create a plasma essentially a
cloud of charged ions which thanks to
their charge can be manipulated by a
magnetic field we can then confine the
plasma with a magnetic field preventing
the ions from hitting the fusion
generator walls and gradually raise its
temperature to extremely high
temperatures that would otherwise melt
every solid material in the universe
raising the temperature of the plasma
causes the ions to move faster and
faster raising the ion's kinetic energy
so high that their speed alone allows
them to punch through the
electromagnetic repulsion and Collide
both of these designs the Tokamak
accelerator use slightly different
methods of magnetic field confinement
generated by Massive superconducting
magnets to achieve Fusion the tokomak
became the leading design today as a
result of a release of information from
the USSR on the Tokamak design in 1968
which showed a tremendous jump in Energy
Efficiency however both designs use the
same fuels the exact reactants we use
have a huge effect on how much energy we
need to put in and what we get out at
the end most reactions use two isotopes
of hydrogen a regular run-of-the-mill
hydrogen has one proton in its nucleus
with one electron in orbit we could
perform fusion with this kind of
hydrogen but the energy we can extract
out of the reaction is very low instead
we frequently combine deuterium and
tritium together where hydrogen normally
has one proton and one electron and no
neutrons deuterium has one proton one
electron and one Neutron while tritium
has one proton one electron and two
neutrons
this combination is used for a couple of
reasons first it has the largest
probability of giving us the exact
result we want
other reactions like a regular hydrogen
to hydrogen reaction have a very high
probability of creating helium-2 which
is unstable and almost instantly decays
into two regular hydrogens again and
releases very little energy in the
process
they have a lower probability of
combining to form deuterium the reaction
we actually want which then go on to
fuse to form helium-3 and finally
helium-4 this is the reaction chain that
powers the Sun but the sun has an
unfathomable amount of particles making
the probability issue completely
irrelevant and the crushing gravity
needed to create the conditions needed
for Fusion we need to supply those
particles and the energy needed to
combine them ourselves and if we can't
extract more energy than we put in
that's just a science experiment not an
energy source we have successfully
created many many Fusion reactions here
on Earth in fact I witnessed the bright
pink flashes of fusion myself while
visiting helion recently we know how to
achieve Fusion the problem we are now
trying to solve is lowering the energy
we need to input while maximizing the
energy we can extract so step one we
need fuels that require less energy
input that release more energy
that's where deuterium and tritium come
in when combined they have a very high
probability of creating helium-4 and
release on average
17.6 Mega electron volts for each and
every Fusion event for comparison
uranium-235 produces 11.4 times this
energy for each fission event but on a
mass basis the deuterium tritium fusion
reaction releases over four times as
much energy as uranium fission and
produces no dangerous radioactive
products helium is actually quite a
useful byproduct being used to cool MRI
machine superconducting magnets to fill
rocket tanks after their propellant has
been expanded to prevent them from
exploding and occasionally to make your
voice sound like Windover Productions
from six years ago thanks real
engineering be sure to go check out and
subscribe to real engineering's Channel
and we will eventually run out of the
gas so having a way to make it ourselves
would be a nice backup deuterium is
fairly common on Earth recurring
naturally in seawater making up about
0.02 percent of hydrogen in seawater and
because deuterium has an extra Neutron
it makes that water molecule heavier
giving its name heavy water
that difference allows us to separate it
through a number of means vacuum
distillation allows us to take advantage
of heavy water's higher boiling point
while the girdler sulfide process
separates heavy water through chemical
reactions we can then simply electrolyze
the heavy water to separate the
deuterium however one of the issues
facing nuclear fusion is the Rarity of
tritium our primary source of tritium is
nuclear reactor moderator pools which
are often filled with heavy water these
pools are designed to absorb the high
energy neutrons given off during nuclear
fusion and in doing so they can become
tritium a hydrogen with two neutrons
this source of tritium is becoming less
prevalent as nuclear power plants are
gradually being shut down around the
world due to competition from cheaper
forms of electricity
currently total Global reserves of
tritium are estimated at just 20
kilograms which is not a lot considering
the eater program the massively
internationally funded fusion generator
being built in France at the moment
estimates the commercial reactor will
need 300 grams of tritium every day to
generate 800 megawatts of electrical
power meaning we would eat through the
entire Global Supply of tritium in just
over two months 800 megawatts is enough
to cover about two percent of France's
Peak power consumption even if we could
continue sourcing tritium from nuclear
fusion reactors they only produce about
100 grams per year
this is a major problem however we do
have a solution in mind we can use the
high energy neutrons spit out from the
fusion reactions to do a bit of alchemy
Wizardry when those high energy neutrons
encounter lithium they can split the
lithium into tritium and helium
providing a steady supply of tritium
rice where it's needed this is done in
what is called a blanket around the
fusion chamber the design of the blanket
is one of the most challenging parts of
a Tokamak fusion generator easier will
test over 180 design variants of this
blanket that will line the donut shaped
interior because the blanket needs to do
a lot more than just breed tritium it is
also where the energy of the fusion
reaction gets converted to heat eighty
percent of the energy of a tritium
deuterium fusion reaction is carried
away by those high energy neutrons in
the form of kinetic energy
we need a way to convert that kinetic
energy to electricity as the fusion
reaction rages in the center of the
magnetically confined plasma neutrons
begin to erupt outwards unaffected by
the magnetic field thanks to their
neutral magnetic charge tokamax converts
the energy of these tiny particles by
slowing them down in the blanket trading
their kinetic energy with atoms in the
blanket to heat energy this heat energy
is then captured by high pressure water
being pumped through cooling channels
converting it to high pressure steam to
drive a steam turbine Humanity's tried
and tested method of creating
electricity the material that fulfills
this role needs some unique properties
first in order to optimize for heating
and tritium breeding we need the
material to be a neutron multiplier when
the high energy Neutron from the fusion
reaction enters the blanket wall we want
it to strike an atom inside the blanket
and release
two neutrons creating an additional
Neutron that allows the blanket to
fulfill both roles generating heat and
tritium beryllium is currently the
leading candidate for this role when the
neutron strikes it it splits into two
helium-4 atoms and two neutrons
beryllium the same material used for the
James Webb Telescope mirrors is the
material of choice because the helium
byproduct does not contaminate the
plasma and critically the material
retains little tritium within itself we
need the tritium to naturally escape the
metal partially because we need to
collect the gas to replenish our fuel
but also because tritium is explosive
just like normal hydrogen however
beryllium does have its problems first
the sheer quantity of beryllium a
commercial Fusion reactor will require
Current Designs call for between 216 and
560 tons this is an issue because
beryllium is extremely expensive due to
the limited supply of the material
annual Global Supply last year amounted
to only 260 tons the entire annual
Global Supply of beryllium could only
just about build one generator next
there are safety issues beryllium can
contain large quantities of uranium
China's beryllium blanket module
contains 100 parts per million uranium
so 0.01 of the blanket is composed of
uranium this isn't an issue for most
components that are usually made out of
beryllium like the beryllium aluminum
copper engine pistons that were banned
from Formula One in 2001 however it
becomes a massive problem when the
uranium is exposed to those high energy
neutrons the same kind of neutrons that
split uranium for fission reactors this
creates fissile Isotopes or in other
words it makes the beryllium Radioactive
if there were 30 parts per million of
uranium to beryllium in a commercial
scale of fusion reactor that would mean
it contains 17 kilograms of natural
uranium and 123 grams of uranium-235 the
uranium needed for fission reactors
the byproducts of this uranium would
make disposing of the blanket at the end
of the generator's life incredibly
difficult this all points to one major
problem that I see with Tokamak Fusion
reactors even if we manage to reach net
energy output these generators don't
solve the biggest problem holding
nuclear energy back cost nuclear fission
power is a Wonder technology of the last
century it promised abundant clean cheap
energy a technology that we scarcely
even dreamed of two centuries ago as we
first discovered the existence of the
atom yes we are closing down nuclear
fission reactors all across the world
when we need that clean energy more than
ever because it's on economical the cost
of building a nuclear fission reactor
and dealing with the radioactive
byproducts when decommissioning it are
the two primary factors making it
uneconomical
and Tokamak reactors are driving
straight towards the exact same economic
problem
however one company is doing it
differently helion the company I visited
to witness nuclear fusion reactors and
interview their brilliant CEO David
curtley they are doing things completely
differently to everyone else in nuclear
fusion research they aren't capturing
energy with steam power eliminating the
need for costly beryllium blankets they
are developing a method of making fuel
on site that doesn't require lithium
instead using the cheap and plentiful
deuterium to create it during fusion and
they are using a completely different
magnetic confinement method to achieve
nuclear fusion temperatures next week we
will be releasing a full-length
documentary about helion right here on
YouTube so make sure to click the Bell
so you can watch it as soon as it's
released
in the meantime you can continue
learning about the physics of nuclear
fusion with this Advanced Physics course
on brilliant called electricity and
magnetism electromagnets play a pivotal
role in many Advanced Technologies
nuclear fusion maglev trains and even
MRI machines it's powerful knowledge to
obtain and you can complete this course
for free by signing up at brilliant.org
forward slash real engineering getting
started on your first course is
completely free but the first 500 people
that sign up with our link will get 20
off brilliant's annual premium
subscription this is the perfect holiday
gift for the lifelong Learner in your
life
I'm a very visual learner I struggle to
understand things just through Reading
text but brilliant includes interactive
elements to help people like me to
quickly grasp Concepts and test
knowledge along the way to ensure you
are understanding the concepts you are
learning this not only makes it fun and
interesting to learn on brilliant but
these bite-sized interactive lessons
make it easier to jump in and out when
you have time they even have a mobile
app allowing you to learn anywhere so
delete all those time wasting games from
your phone and replace them with
brilliant brilliant focuses on
facilitating Effective Education that
will help you progress in your learning
goals whether it's professional career
advancement or just for fun for lifelong
Learners brilliant or adding content
monthly so there's always something new
to learn we even have our own real
engineering course that explores the
science behind Rockets including orbits
and Center pedal acceleration you can
get started for free by clicking the
link on screen right now and the first
500 people to do so will get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription